this new movie did you see Bros I don't
even understand I missed everything I
don't understand what it is I I was told
that I'm not allowed to see it because
I'm straight I don't even I didn't know
it was a gay movie it's a gay movie it's
a gay rom-com and what happened it
bombed mm-hmm uh it's Billy Eichner it's
someone else I don't know uh they tried
to do
they tried to do a movie about just
dudes [ __ ] okay and America did not
come and I I don't think it said
America's homophobic because the
birdcage did 185 million worldwide
Brokeback Mountain was huge but this
movie for whatever reason has done 4.8
million opening for Bros solo that it
also means many lgbtq viewers didn't
show because everyone's gay now yeah you
can't blame straight people because if
you go on the internet everyone's kind
of gay if you look at their bios so they
also didn't do see this movie I didn't
even know in there and I didn't even
know what it was or existed it was
called Bros I thought it was about bro
dudes I didn't know it was about gay
guys it's about a gay guy who's a
podcaster it's about a podcaster that's
why no one wins yes I've been a
podcaster and a dude who's kind of like
a a jock and they meet up and they're
not releasing it in the Middle East
because there's graphic sex scenes oh
really yeah there's some graphic here's
the thing with a movie like this it's
got to be so funny a movie like this has
got to be so funny that you have to be
the you know the dude to suggest it to
your other friends and not seem gay
right so the movie has to be so good
that you have to go guys you know
because it'll never be easy to do you
bring someone I go we gotta go see Bros
right there's not a laugh and it's just
men [ __ ] your friends go well now
we've learned now we've learned
something about you you've come out
thanks for telling us what you have to
do with this because it would start
where it's like you would you would
literally have to be like hey man you
know maybe go see a movie
you know it's like a bunch of dudes and
they're like they're all sitting there
and you gotta go hey man like uh I don't
know what's out you know uh
maybe uh there's something uh what about
Bros and they one of them's gonna go
isn't that the gay movie that's your
moment that's your moment you have to
hit them with bullet points you have to
be like no no no no no they're like dude
aren't they sucking each other off for
two hours go no no no no it's it's so
funny and you know Steve Martin's in it
or whoever like you gotta have so much
star power in that one movie yeah like
dude did you see the trailer it's
[ __ ] hilarious look at the trailer
like it has to be so aggressively good
so funny just to get through you have to
actually be like or you have to like
[ __ ] a girl in the theater yes you're
watching it like yeah this is cool too
you got to be like listen I was [ __ ]
my fish the other night and you know
what she wanted to go see this movie
Bros yeah and now she's left town but I
figure we're all together right over
here we're here maybe we'll go see Bros
and and the the thing is it's really so
they've spent an estimated 30 to 40
million to promote Bros because it's
everywhere if you look I haven't even I
know it's hard now
it's you haven't even seen any of it I
saw one sign that said Bros and it was
two guys and you know I thought the
movie honestly was about I thought about
straight guys pretending to be gay or
something I was like oh are they doing
this in 2006 like we didn't hear about
the metoo movement kind of [ __ ] real
like on woke like yeah it's like the
Sandler movie what was it called Adam
Sandler that movie where they pretended
to Get Right Now Pronounce You Chuck and
Larry and it was like who was it was
Kevin James right even James Sandler and
they pretended to be they pretend to be
because he wanted a bang what's her name
with the great ass sorry yeah I remember
the same yeah it's my show you're not
say anything you want what's her name
anyway Justin Timberlake's ex-wife
Jessica Beale yeah so it's they
pretended to be gay and they were
firemen yeah they were firemen can't be
gay
so we were thinking like I was I was
wondering it's like the marketing in
this number one the the thing Bros right
there b-r-o-s with the thing like this
you have to Market this very differently
right this cannot be marketed as like
hey everybody
it's a gay movie you have to Market this
as a [ __ ] hilarious movie where guys
[ __ ] in it like there's graphic sex in
it yeah dude sex and it's got to be so
over the top like dude sex can be really
funny but it's got to be really over the
top what's it about is it just so we'll
we'll try to get the gay sex right no I
I think it's it's about are they
brothers who are gay that might be a
problem it's about here hold on go go
back for a second Bobby a neurotic
podcast host who's happy to go on Tinder
dates and content not to have a serious
relationship that all changes when he
meets Aaron an equally detached lawyer
who likes to play the field
repeatedly drawn to each other both men
begin to show their vulnerable sides if
you go see this you are gay right you're
coming out sure like the description of
that if you're paying money to see that
movie you're gay I tell you they call it
the gay movie or the yeah you're the gay
test yeah making more money yeah Bros
was a bad name no this is this is you're
a gay movie if this was like any other
type of movie yeah where it's a guy like
me uh who's a garbage man in Staten
Island and who has to tell his fat wife
he sucks [ __ ] yeah and she's throwing
[ __ ] at him and calling him and she's
like you're a [ __ ] yeah that's a movie
people watch because they go and then
you can sneak in some disgusting you
know not that gay sex is just but I mean
like it should be in a comedy right gay
sex in a comedy should be funny sure
just like straight sex and a rom-com
should be funny yes like it shouldn't be
like hot no I think any sex in a comedy
should be kind of like what's going on I
would argue this though I would argue
that if you're gonna put a sex scene in
you they've yet to do this put in a real
super hardcore yeah [ __ ] scene into a
comedy come on your face I think this is
that really supposedly
yeah I think it's so graphic
really people gay people aren't going to
watch this because they're turned off
how graphic your gay voice is it gay you
know like it's okay for me for me
it's so much [ __ ] apparently and I
don't know because Billy eichers come
out and said listen you're all
homophobic you didn't go to see here's
the thing respectably Eichner you're not
a big celebrity sure you did There's
Billy on the Street it's to show people
watching taxis
you what does he do right he runs around
and he's like doesn't isn't this his
show he's like hey I'm on the street
everybody and who are you I don't like
it it's very mean he's a mean guy he
walks on the street and he says hey I
don't like your hair they go why he goes
you're a [ __ ] and he leaves I'm like
this is not a show it's like a show that
legitimizes hate crimes yes you go oh
you punch that gay guy he yeah that's
what the whole show is is he chases
people on the street and make you answer
fast yeah he goes what's going on with
you you know and you're you're like I
don't know
um what are the three branches of
government you're like I don't really
know like yeah he's like all right you
ignorant Pig and then he just runs away
and so he's the guy so listen this let
me read a review here this is not a
movie for teens of any age it's
basically soft core porn of any age
teens of any age well Euphoria which is
the biggest show on TV [ __ ] great and
it's a great show I love that I've
always wanted to be in that as some
unimportant I'll edit you in thing can
you yeah I don't understand a man we'll
just do some scenes and I'll put you in
it now you're in it I've always wanted
to just so I could like stand next to
jack up a lordy and just be like it's
another day on the you know it's another
day for guys like us you know just
something stupid but it's softcore porn
right it's a very like see now this goes
it's not a movie for somebody by the way
brought their teens to Bros and is very
very angry about this some parrot said
we're going to Bros I don't know how
that happened they walked in and they're
like we're going to brows yeah this is
not a movie for teens of any age it's
basically softcore porn why would you
let your 16 year old watch a movie with
fairly graphic orgies gay or straight
our standards for what is considered
appropriate entertainment for teens has
reached a new low I don't know if this
was Mark it into teens and then the next
person undergoes hilarious and raunchy
I'm gonna go see this movie and see if I
get some lift it's very exciting for me
yeah I don't know what's going on here I
don't know how graphic it is it doesn't
matter yeah I mean let me tell you this
after you get married yeah ever you
become gay you become everything I am I
am it's like prison you know people go
to prison you have to forget right I
will [ __ ] anything yeah and I'll do and
and I watch these things I try to test
myself to see where I can go sexually
what I can watch I'm gonna go to this
movie
just and I'm gonna try to jerk off yeah
see what happens I love this article it
goes Bros review Billy agner won't play
nice for the straights it's like why is
everything
so angry I know
it's annoying it's like why is
everything so just
make a really funny movie and sneak some
graphic right sex into it I knew when I
would try to get my friends to watch gay
stuff it always had to have something
else going on okay stuff give me a hint
like a movie
like what's a gay movie just give me I
need to try to think of a good uh gay
movie
bird cage yeah brilliant right Nicholson
May one of the funniest grips ever
written right you easily go do this
[ __ ] it's actually really funny yeah
okay
you know Twilight is gay very gay very
good yeah but it's you know it's the guy
with the shirt it's like yeah you gotta
have some other you got to have like
yeah but there's a hot chick in it
because there's a lot of you gotta
Target the market of closeted people yes
they want to see the movie yeah closeted
people want to go to see the movie some
of them are gonna go see it alone it's a
gay movie with a different hook it's a
different hook you gotta be able to
because there's got someone's got to be
able to sit through this movie fully
erect and walk out a straight man with
their friends and if that doesn't happen
you failed as a producer here's what I
do I open a business I open a theater
where the theater our whole vibe is we
tell you every movie sold out except the
gay movie so you go hey let's go see the
new Transformers interesting right you
walk up you go two three four for
Transformers and they go sorry yeah all
we have is uh raping ass sex for four
hours and you go well we already paid
for the Uber and now you're in now
you're in right well I want to see the
lesbian version of this right the
lesbian version of this where I don't
know what it would call like how extreme
is it gonna get they just call it dykes
and it's just two women on like a farm
in Wisconsin just eating each other's
[ __ ] for two hours yeah and again I
understand America's homophobic people
say homophobic [ __ ] about me all the
time you know it's the least bad of what
they say about me but I understand that
the country's homophobic but you got to
see it as a challenge just work around
it right just work around it but also
like
yeah okay the country's homophobic but
the major markets aren't they're not New
York L.A homophobia is not the reason
for this failure that's what I agree the
reason for this failure is it's probably
not funny like yeah sorry can we watch a
trailer on this or will we get totally
[ __ ] like I mean I don't mean like we
can watch a trailer right why are you
looking at me I'm a guest I don't know
let me throw this at you you also have
to understand that if they would have
marketed as there's all this gay sex
scenes yes you're also going to get the
Bros who are like Yo dude let's go watch
that gay movie yes I mean those guys are
gonna go see it as a bit you know
because they think that's funny you have
to allow them right space to ironically
yes go see this bro movie Let's Hear It
Let's watch this hey guys it's Bobby
Lieber coming to you from the future
home of the lgbtq plus Museum see you
ready I'm out they're talking about the
lgbtq museum
this happens e bisexual awareness
bisexual Awareness Week
let's get a month and we get a week
so what's happening didn't you this is
habitat too I mean he's great he's done
great stuff situation you're gonna
thrive
let me tell you what's Progressive now
being alone I love my life I love my
freedom I love my Independence that's
kind of sad that I don't want to be in a
throuple I don't even want to be in a
couple
Bobby I had sex with that 65 year old
Jesus he's ripped I don't know it's like
they injected steroids into Dumbledore
oh my God that's not it
right you know when you a line like that
it's like they injected steroids into
Dumbledore yeah that's not it okay good
comedies were like 10 years ago yeah I
mean like Will Ferrell the [ __ ] those
like movies the Adam McKay that genre
was like dude that [ __ ] was so [ __ ]
we're done you could have snuck in
hardcore anal into Step Brothers no one
would have cared I would I would have
loved it it would have been fine yeah
because it was so [ __ ] funny you put
a fisting scene in the middle of Tommy
Boy fine
I I'll say this I'll throw this out to
your fans edit a hardcore sex scene into
Step Brothers right let's see if it
makes it better yeah I guarantee it does
right I guarantee it's just Larry
steenberg and getting plowed yeah yeah
the two brothers right Bros it's about
step Bros and they're [ __ ] re-edit
Steph Bros line through step and just
edit hot sex between Will Ferrell yeah
and Philip Seymour Huffman what's his
name uh John C Riley yeah that Phillips
Robin has died of heroin overdose
that'll happen very sad very sad this is
what happens well my whole feeling on
the whole thing is I hate blaming
homophobia I think you just gotta do
better [ __ ] right but I also understand
that like there is that's real to a
degree where people just go yeah it's
hard for a dude to suggest to his
buddies let's go see Bros
but we got to think about like first of
all the title right the title right Bros
is stupid it's a dumb type because some
guys gotta say to a guy in a pickup
truck you want to just go see Bros
it's the worst
title
the truck have had a day already and
they're just going I mean none of this
is working out yeah let's just go see
Bros let's go see Bros do you want to
see that guy suck off that other guy I
mean I'll check it out yeah I mean it's
it's a wild moment you call it gay sex
or getting more views I think honestly I
think they didn't go they didn't go far
enough yeah they didn't go far enough I
think they went to medium that whole
trailer was medium right they go pull
back or go all in oh go all in all in
yeah all in I'm in yeah which is or it's
eyes wide shot with Billy eichman the
most annoying person on television
people do not react to him the way he
thinks people react to him well they'll
do his back like he doesn't he doesn't
come off like a fun guy you want to
spend two hours with no he hates me I
don't even know him he I know he hates
me I think he blocked me on Twitter I'm
not sure but he hates like so a lot of
people in the movie not fans of mine
because it's like I get it whatever you
know I'd be one of them call me a pet
homosexual once because I was just
friends with Rogan in them what does
that mean it means like I'm friends with
straight people let me say this though
yeah these guys maybe this is
disrespectful yeah 99 of the time I
forget you're gay that's true not in
like whatever but yeah he would say they
would say that I'm doing the wrong thing
because they would say that I'm trying
to assimilate into the straight World
instead of walking around spitting Comet
people
that's what they would say instead of me
because for me it would be weirder if I
went harder to get like that would be
just as disingenuous right if I got on
stage I was like hey [ __ ] right stop it
like that would be strange and I would
argue too I want to just I forget you're
getting the way I bet people forget I'm
Italian that's right you know what I
mean like yeah it's a giant part of my
life yeah but there's just so you don't
walk around with a full-blooded Italian
shirts no you don't talk about the
mother country no it's just not you've
got other things going a lot of things
going on man yeah